today is the 11th birthday of Twitter
that's right folks 11 years ago Donald
Trump was just writing crazy things on
post-it notes
[Laughter]
[Music]
he wouldn't yell send when he put it on
there yeah speaking of Trump today
President Trump gave NASA one its 19.5
present Trump gave NASA 19 point five
billion dollars to develop a manned
mission to Mars
very cool yeah Trump said he wants to
see if Mars can sustain life and a
casino because there's some money there
one leads to the other one leads yeah
days after we get a guy there or a girl
whatever it's been reported that Donald
Trump campaign advisor Roger stone has a
tattoo of Richard Nixon across his
shoulders yes and get this ladies he's
single
[Applause]
I like to be I'd like to see the tattoo
shop that has that in their catalog as
yeah agent crew oh and Nixon Oliver Nix
yeah
thank you I'll have a Dwight Eisenhower
[ __ ] stamp yeah yeah
Amazon has introduced a new feature that
scans what you're wearing and gives you
clothing advice
yeah the feature is called Trevor and
it's Alexa's [ __ ] gay brother
this is crazy a robot has been taught
how to write rap songs by being fed more
than 6-thousand kanye west's lyrics yeah
yeah the only problem is now the robot
thinks it's God
[Applause]
you